before photography illustrators brought
fashion to life a century of fashion
illustration is now being celebrated at
a new exhibition here in New York and
Anthony Mason is here with the story
Anthony good morning first full
disclosure this story is personal for me
by late stepfather Henry Kohler started
as a fashion illustrator working for
magazines like Vogue and Town and
Country in the 50s and 60s one of his
drawings is included in the new
exhibition at the Society of
illustrators here in New York fashion
illustration of course was usually
commercial work but these illustrators
also had an art all their own an art
that the exhibition shows is alive and
well that's perfect Bill Donovan started
sketching as a boy and knew what he
wanted the moment he saw Audrey Hepburn
sweep into a ballroom in a GEVO she gown
in the 1954 film Sabrina to me you know
she was a Swan floating across the floor
and I wanted to draw that I didn't want
to take a picture I didn't want to
design it I wanted to draw it Donovan
now artist in residence at christian
dior beauty has drawn for Vogue and
Vanity Fair how many pieces in the
exhibition 63 pieces and he's co-curator
of the new exhibition fashion
illustrators the visionaries at the
Society of illustrators in New York what
do you see in these words oh god I see
passion I just see the love of line and
color and shape and energy and flair
putting all those pieces together to
make work to me that is like visual
poetry the exhibit looks at a century of
illustration starting with early giants
like Carl Erickson who worked for Vogue
for more than 40 years beginning in 1916
and Rene Boucher who sketched many CBS
greats like Jack Benny and Edward Armour
oh but was best known as a fashion
illustrator the Great's all had a
distinct style like this Tod res drawing
from the 1950s I mean look at the
feathered hat it's it's chaotic it's
energized it's one of my favorite
drawings or Joe EULA Halston
creative director who dashed off this
sketch of Martha Graham the brilliance
of it is the spontaneity the energy and
you could feel her dancing you could
feel her moving women illustrators were
rare in women's fashion but Barbara
Pearlman broke through I love this piece
because she's striking and she's staring
right back at you some of these
illustrators became real stars most of
them are stars most of them are
legendary almost every single person we
selected has a legacy like Glenn
Tunstall who made his name drawing for
the fashion bible Women's Wear Daily in
the early 1970s and I found people
recognized me
I would even get fan mail you know what
they knew Tunstall who came from Detroit
was a pioneer I was there as the first
black illustrator at women's wear was
that your dream job yes I think it was
everyone that was a fashion artist what
makes a great fashion illustrator it's
this fluency with drawing whereby not
only can you draw what you see but you
can easily exaggerate is it also during
what you feel enjoying what you feel you
bring your personality yourself into it
the commercial options for illustrators
have dwindled with photographers
replacing them on the runway and
magazines in decline is the magazine
market pretty much gone I don't want to
answer that fashion illustrator Sarah
Singh it still exists because people
want to do it and I want to do it why do
you want to do it because it's fun
I've had it ever since I was little that
I need to draw it's an addiction Singh
who works quickly in ink will then scan
her illustrations and alter them in the
computer she's drawn for Vogue Elle
Decor and Tiffany and also shows her
work on her Instagram page when you get
your work published online it's up
forever
before it might just end up in the
dentist office you get appreciated yes
you could appreciate it not fed but
appreciated Singh says bill Donovan is
one of a new generation of illustrators
keeping the craft alive a lot of people
don't take this seriously as art but I
bet you see it as art I see it as art
and I've always seen it as art it's a
special form of art that doesn't exist
anywhere else my intent is the capture
of boma when a woman walks into a
restaurant and she's beautiful and she
just quietly turns over her shoulder and
gives a glance so alluring and that's
what I try to capture that essence that
spontaneous moment that happens there's
an intimacy that is created when when
you're drawing live I think people want
some of that back it's so interesting
what's happened to fashion illustration
it's become there's a new sort of
interest in it in part because it's it's
disappearing to some degree yeah you
know it's like the photograph replaced
it but the photograph is also helping
bring it back because it's so unusual
now yeah it is almost new again this
exhibit at the Society of illustrators
runs through March 7th it's by the way
that place is it is it like a hidden gem
of New York you go up the stairs and
there are old book illustrations of
magazine astre illustrations from the
last 50 years it's a fabulous place and
I encourage you to go if you're here
tell us what you felt when you saw your
stepfathers picture up
I grew up with them so it's like you
know if you walk out the front door at
CVS to the left of that front door here
there's a drawing of Edward amar oh
that's by Rene Boucher who we mentioned
in this piece I knew who Rene Boucher
was cuz my stepfather told me when I was
growing up and I was like oh that's that
guy he told me about so I have this
connection to this thing which is fairly
unusual but it comes from being
surrounded by this he was my stepfather
was drawing all the time
I you know I can't believe that there's
any question as to whether this is art
because it is such a beautiful way of
capturing the moment but as you said you
get that emotion from and it's your
emotion that you're bringing into it
people think of something as commercial
it can't be art but all of these
illustrators had an art thanks big glad
to have you
nice to be here